[Music]
you wanna play games do you Batman save
the city or catch your greatest enemy do
you think you might greatest enemy well
Drive you to one-up them the way that I
do Superman
Superman's not a bad guy I like to fight
around are you seriously saying that
there is nothing special about us there
is no us
never will be now they're gonna defuse
that bomb
[Music]
hey computer I'm home master Bruce you
need to take responsibility for your
life and it starts by raising the young
orphan you adopted it's the it's better
I can only look you in the eyes right
now Gotham City is the most crime-ridden
city in the world we need to team up
with Batman
what introducing the worst villains of
the history of the universe the Riddler
Catwoman have been ghost calendar man
and the kind of eight games are you
making some of those up nope they're all
real
you guys ready just save Gotham see
I am so sorry soon as I get back to the
Batcave
I will make sure that Alfred puts
seatbelts on there but for the time
being I'm just gonna put my arm right
here have to rename this the bun bow
bill life and it starts by raising your
son I'm sorry I literally have no idea
what you're talking about
the young orphan you adopted at the gala